every time you guys come in here you're
like oh we're just a bunch of happy gol
lucky guys you know once again through
no fault of our own we found ourselves
in another pickle you tried to kill your
bosses one of them ended up dead now you
want to perpetrate a kidnapping you
three of the craziest criminals I've
ever seen in my life one of those
useless machines they used to make was
called an
MRI and if we had any of those left the
doctors would have been able to find the
cyst in my wife's Brain before she died
and said afterwards then she'd have been
the one sitting there listening to
this welcome to the nerd
lab yeah I've never seen electromag
suspension on a bike before zero
resistance faster bike but not fast
enough ah but what you don't know is
that dirt Dave Dave won't be using his
bazooka serum Medusa serum Medusa serum
on anybody that part is accurate show
them
Rico
it's a non animu and your cameraman over
there Caster hello I'm
pox let's get locked
in you're all from the capital plutar
got you out don't expect much chitchat
from him Capital cut his tongue out
years ago and no it wasn't any sort of
rescue of that's what you
mean we all fled on our own for
this for you